nevada has now surpassed three thousand
deaths from coven 19. that is since the
pandemic started
47 more were reported yesterday cases
are up more than 1700 statewide
close to 2 000 people are currently
hospitalized with coven 19. here's a
look at those numbers
coping 19 is now the leading cause of
death here in nevada
700 people died from the disease in
december alone
officials with the state's kova task
force say new cases are down over the
past few days
but they do fear the dip isn't because
of a lack of spread
but because fewer people are getting
tested
we've been reporting pretty low numbers
of new cases and
general testing but we really do think
that that's a result of people not
getting tested on christmas day and
probably
folks that do get sick as a result of
the holiday or
get sick around that time will have be
seeking testing in the next week or so
nevada's test positivity rate remains
the second highest in the country as of
last
week 20 percent of tests are coming back
positive
that suggests a lot of people are
carrying the virus and don't know it